Pre-processing the
data can be difficult,
but, luckily, R's packages
provide easy-to-use functions
for the most common tasks.
In this video, we'll
load and process our data
in R. In your R
console, let's load
the data set tweets.csv
with the read.csv function.
But since we're working
with text data here,
we need one extra
argument, which is
stringsAsFactors=FALSE.
So we'll call our
data set tweets.
And we'll use the read.csv
function to read in the data
file tweets.csv, but then
we'll add the extra argument
stringsAsFactors=FALSE.
You'll always need to add
this extra argument when
working on a text
analytics problem
so that the text is
read in properly.
Now let's take a
look at the structure
of our data with
the str function.
We can see that we have 1,181
observations of two variables,
the text of the
tweet, called Tweet,
and the average sentiment
score, called Avg for average.
The tweet texts are
real tweets that we
found on the internet directed
to Apple with a few cleaned up
words.
We're more interested
in being able to detect
the tweets with clear
negative sentiment,
so let's define a new
variable in our data
set tweets called Negative.
And we'll set this equal to
as.factor(tweets$Avg = -1).
This will set tweets$Negative
equal to true if the average
sentiment score is less than
or equal to negative 1 and will
set tweets$Negative equal to
false if the average sentiment
score is greater
than negative 1.
Let's look at a table of
this new variable, Negative.
We can see that 182 of the
1,181 tweets, or about 15%,
are negative.
Now to pre-process
our text data so
that we can use the
bag of words approach,
we'll be using the tm
text mining package.
We'll need to install and
load two packages to do this.
First, let's install the
package tm, and go ahead
and select a CRAN
mirror near you.
As soon as that package
is done installing
and you're back at
the blinking cursor,
go ahead and load that package
with the library command.
Then we also need to install
the package snowballC.
This package helps us
use the tm package.
And go ahead and load the
snowball package as well.
One of the concepts
introduced by the tm package
is that of a corpus.
A corpus is a
collection of documents.
We'll need to convert our tweets
to a corpus for pre-processing.
tm can create a corpus
in many different ways,
but we'll create it from the
tweet column of our data frame
using two functions,
corpus and vector source.
We'll call our corpus
"corpus" and then
use the corpus and the
vector source functions
called on our tweets variable
of our tweets data set.
So that's tweets$Tweet.
We can check that
this has worked
by typing corpus and seeing
that our corpus has 1,181 text
documents.
And we can check that the
documents match our tweets
by using double brackets.
So type corpus[[1]].
This shows us the first
tweet in our corpus.
Now we're ready to start
pre-processing our data.
Pre-processing is easy in tm.
Each operation, like stemming
or removing stop words,
can be done with
one line in R, where
we use the tm_map function.
Let's try it out by changing
all of the text in our tweets
to lowercase.
To do that, we'll
replace our corpus
with the output of the
tm_map function, where
the first argument is
the name of our corpus
and the second argument
is what we want to do.
In this case, tolower.
tolower is a standard
function in R,
and this is like when we pass
mean to the tapply function.
We're passing the
tm_map function
a function to use on our corpus.
Let's see what that did by
looking at our first tweet
again.
Go ahead and hit the up
arrow twice to get back
to corpuscorpus{[1] and now we can
see that all of our letters are
lowercase.
Now let's remove
all punctuation.
This is done in a
very similar way,
except this time we
give the argument
removePunctuation
instead of tolower.
Hit the up arrow twice,
and in the tm_map function,
delete tolower, and
type removePunctuation.
Let's see what this did
to our first tweet again.
Now the comma after "say",
the exclamation point after
"received", and the @ symbols
before "Apple" are all gone.
Now we want to remove the
stop words in our tweets.
tm provides a list of stop
words for the English language.
We can check it out by typing
stopwords("english") [1:10].
We see that these
are words like "I,"
"me," "my," "myself," et cetera.
Removing words can be done
with the removeWords argument
to the tm_map function, but
we need one extra argument
this time-- what the stop words
are that we want to remove.
We'll remove all of
these English stop words,
but we'll also remove
the word "apple"
since all of these tweets
have the word "apple"
and it probably won't be
very useful in our prediction
problem.
So go ahead and hit the
up arrow to get back
to the tm_map function, delete
removePunctuation and, instead,
type removeWords.
Then we need to add one
extra argument, c("apple").
This is us removing
the word "apple."
And then stopwords("english").
So this will remove
the word "apple"
and all of the
English stop words.
Let's take a look
at our first tweet
again to see what happened.
Now we can see that we have
significantly fewer words, only
the words that are
not stop words.
Lastly, we want to stem our
document with the stem document
argument.
Go ahead and scroll back up
to the removePunctuation,
delete removePunctuation,
and type stemDocument.
If you hit Enter and then
look at the first tweet again,
we can see that this took
off the ending of "customer,"
"service," "received,"
and "appstore."
In the next video, we'll
investigate our corpus
and prepare it for our
prediction problem.